I talked to so many smart fantastic
ambitious idealistic hard-working kids
and there right out of college there in
their entry-level jobs and I'll ask them
how is it going and they'll say I think
I'm gonna quit and I'm like why they say
to me I'm not making an impact I'm like
you know you've been here eight months
right but the problem is this sense of
impatience it's as if an entire
generation is standing at the foot of a
mountain they know exactly what they
want they can see the summit what they
can't see is the mountain this large a
movable object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what I'm
talking about take a helicopter climb I
don't care but there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are journeys the problem is this entire
generation has an institutionalized
sense of impatience and do they have the
patience to go on the journey to
maintain love to feel fulfilled or do
they just quit and on to the next dump
and on to the next sometimes you're the
problem we've seen this happen all too
recently with our new men of science and
empirical studies and these men of
finance who are smarter than the rest of
us until the thing collapsed and they
blamed everything else except themselves
and my point is is take accountability
for your actions you can take all the
credit in the world for the things that
you do right as long as you also take
responsibility for the things you do
wrong it must be a balanced equation you
don't get it one way and not the other
you get to take credit when you also
take accountability you just watch two
amazing clips from Simon sonic take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you